- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy,
and we're entering into
yet another back to school,
but this is a back to
school that's very unusual
compared to all others.
We hope that we're finally going to get
to some level of normalcy
as we see the light at
the end of the tunnel
with the pandemic, at
least in some places.
I know a lot of parts of
the world are still going
through some of the worst
impacts of the pandemic.
But as we hopefully get to that
point and go back to school,
I just wanted to say how excited we are
to partner with y'all.
The pandemic has been tough.
It's been tough on many
dimensions of our life,
but especially education.
As I always say,
and people are surprised
to hear it from me,
if I had to pick between an
amazing in-person experience
with an amazing educator
versus the best technology in the world,
I would pick the amazing
in-person experience.
Now, I don't think there
has to be a trade off.
I think the best is the
best of both worlds.
But you can imagine, people
haven't had the benefit
of being in the room together,
being able to have all of the intangibles
that goes with being an in-person school.
So there's a lot of work to do.
Obviously all of us here at Khan Academy
have been doing our best to play a part
in keeping everyone learning,
supporting everyone as
the pandemic went on.
But the real work is
actually going to be now,
as we go into back to school.
A lot of folks have been talking
about unfinished learning
or learning loss.
And every summer, there's
some learning loss.
Kids forget things, and
they're not learning things.
But we can imagine with a year,
year and a half of pandemic schooling,
some of the kids who
we're most concerned about
actually fell off the radar.
And many, many other kids
weren't able to learn as much,
and even the kids and the
learners, I should say,
of all ages who were able to learn,
there's other things
that fell by the wayside,
the socialization, the connection,
the patterns of school.
So for all of you parents,
students, teachers,
donors to Khan Academy,
first of all, thank you for
being on this journey with us.
But I'm confident, as well,
that as we go into this period,
it's not gonna be easy,
but if we work together,
figure out ways to finish
that unfinished learning,
there might be a post-pandemic world
where we can accelerate learning
together faster than ever.
So I look forward to
going on that journey,
and welcome back to school.